one of the most important attributes of
origami is once we have studied and
understood the way paper folds and
unfolds we can apply those patterns the
things that are very different from
paper I hope by bringing the tools of
mathematics into my origami design that
I can then fold something that's
beautiful and it's unexpected my name is
Robert Lang I'm a physicist and an
origami artist origami is the Japanese
name for the art of folded paper and
most origami is folded from a single
sheet of paper with no cuts or tears
I have loved origami entire line I
pursued it ever since I was a kid but my
study was science engineering I worked
for NASA doing research on lasers but
throughout that whole time I had been
pursuing origami developing designs
writing books so in 2001 I quit my job
to try to make a career out of Oregon
I've worked on a couple of different
folding patterns that were round and
would wrap into a cylindrical geometry
to fit in Muraki and I developed an air
bag in a car that inflates from a small
folded bundle so whenever an engineer
creates something that opens and closes
in a control way they can make use of
the folding patterns of origami over the
years math has allowed me to realize as
an artist shapes and creations that I
couldn't achieve in the other way
traditional origami was relatively
simple
the designs would have taken maybe 20 or
30 steps at most but today origami
pieces can be so confident that they can
have tens hundreds maybe even a thousand
steps when I'm folding it's like working
with an old friend like dancing with a
partner whose moves I know if I move
this way I know my partner's going to
move that way and so I explore the math
develop the equation solve the equations
create the folding pattern and then I
find out what it looks like and as often
as not it is beautiful for me the
driving force is that there's always
something new to try a new problem a new
subject a new shape that I didn't think
I was able to create before but now I
think I know how to realize and each
time I solve a problem you get this
wonderful feeling and you want more of
those feelings it's 1995 your word
processor is open before you press a
single key you make the most important
decision of your life what fun do I use
all the usual fonts are too conventional
there were very few very casual
typefaces that you could use and keep
scrolling to stately to boring but then
it pops out of the menu what is this fun
it was so different than everything else
the way it flows is strange
it had irregularity about it and
uniquely flawed the stems aren't
perfectly straight little quite wobbly
this is the font you want and in that
moment you and millions of other people
click on the button that says
Comic Sans how did it fall to those
loads and cherish come to dominate the
world my name is Vincent Khmer I was a
type of graphic engineer at Microsoft I
considered it too lotsa fonts like
webdings
trebuchet and must notably common sense
so it's all my fault
to understand comics and you have to
understand its creator used before his
work at Microsoft Linton was working on
his undergrad in New York City we went
to university in the 1980s I was a quite
young rebellious fine art student and
spend a lot of time in art spaces and
I'd walk through the galleries of the
old Soho and look at paintings and then
art work to him what separated good art
from batter with this simple benchmark
if you didn't notice them
I consider that was bad and if he did
notice it was good because least they
made you stop and look it either shocked
you or you really liked it but if you
didn't even notice and he's walked
through it was a disaster since it would
take that philosophy to Microsoft where
he was challenged to make a playful font
for a program called Microsoft Bob and
so I looked at Batman and the Watchmen
and pretty much tried to draw on the
computer something that looks similar to
that but not copying it so that's how
Comic Sans was made by just looking at
comic books and comic characters not
everyone was a fan of the fonts quirks
my boss Robert Norton he didn't really
like the font and he thought it should
be a bit more typographic and I argued
and said no it should be weird and I
thought it stood out and it wasn't
boring typography that's in in a school
book though the font didn't make it to
the release of Microsoft Bob it was
eventually pre-installed on every
Macintosh by 1996 I started to see it
when it was in in the wild so dirty the
first one I remember was neon sign over
a store called fun stamps that's what I
realize it's going to get used any way
anybody wants to use it and that just
snowballed from there
Vaughn spread like wildfire and waves
and some didn't even imagine when I
travel the world and see it in on beach
towel war memorial on bread Street sign
on everything it's over exposure even
spirit a group of designers to start an
anti comic sans movement I thought it
was funny I didn't really find it
offensive after all these years
Vincent finds himself content with how
history will remember him and Comic Sans
is not one of the better pieces of art a
conceptual it's one of the best things
I've ever done it probably is the best
thing I have ever done
[Music]
you
okay so everybody knows Michelangelo
Italian Renaissance hipster beard he's
made a few things you might have seen
this naked guy this crazy ceiling a
couple of paintings but did you also
know that he is the mastermind behind
one of arts most innovative inventions
paint-by-number way back in the 1500s
Michelangelo was the man top dog he had
all the popes on speed-dial he was so
busy he used students to help him with
his work and he started pre numbering
sections of his paintings and ceilings
so that students could follow the design
see where this is headed fast-forward in
1949 Dan Robbins was an artist at the
Palmer paint company in Michigan and he
had an idea he created painting kits and
pre numbered them like Michelangelo did
and paint-by-numbers was born pretty
soon it was hugely popular seriously
everybody was doing it for goodness
sakes J Edgar Hoover has one hanging in
the White House today Dan Robbins with
the help of the rest of us is probably
the most displayed artist in the world
sorry Michelangelo
[Music]
the year was 1996 it was a different era
for memes before viral videos before
anybody argued over whether it's a gift
for a jiff its gift jeff has peanut
butter there was the dancing baby
[Music]
what is the dancing baby who better to
ask that his father Michel Gerard what
are you doing here
the dancing baby remember I'm a dancing
baby
well Robert and Laurier and I work
together to design animation the idea
was to show that movement could be
programmed and projected onto different
characters so Autodesk the company that
Michael worked for started appending
around the software to other developers
and animators it was just another demo
film until it landed on the LucasArts
server it was there that Ron Lussier
tweaked the original file converted it
into a gif and Zippin email would change
his life forever so we thought we should
ask Ron about his experience but finally
it turns out now every time that you've
got male voice ranked welcome you've got
mail
files done goodbye it was another
goddamn dancing baby even I got an email
that goddamn dancing baby from that
point on it was unstoppable
everywhere you looked there was a
density maybe on television on t-shirts
on ties and commercials even boxers
boxers
yes Michael boxers
it's all big the question what is it
about the dancing maybe that makes it so
irresistible what does it say about us
have you heard of he uncanny valley it's
a paradox where the more a
computer-generated figure resembles a
human the more we become revolted by the
dancing baby is the uncanny valley
the dancing baby is the uncanny valley
it's been over two decades since Gerard
and his team unleashed their monstrosity
of the world because he regret it yes
100%
[Music]
the main difficulties of working with
any vulnerable or fragile work of
cultural heritage is the respect you
have to have for that object technology
is at a point right now where we can
record the surface of an object down to
fractions of a millimeter and it's
through this kind of understanding that
allows you to communicate across time
and across cultures the task of heritage
protection and preservation is a real
challenge the mission of bekhten
foundation is to record cultural
heritage so in the event that there's a
disaster or an accident we have the data
to know what was there exactly as it is
we're hiring a number of methods to
return that information into the
physical world we're doing CNC milling
we're doing 3d printing but we're trying
to go beyond that a facsimile of the
Borg are in each other the facsimile of
the tomb of Tutankhamen in the Valley of
the Kings an exact facsimile of very
native wedding at Cana
[Music]
[Applause]
the biggest project that's going on at
the moment is an exact facsimile of the
tomb of Seti the first which will be
given to the people of Egypt as soon as
it's finished two hundred years ago the
concern was not one of preservation the
concern was one of Indiana Jones and
discovery and excitement and cultural
acquisitions the tombs in the Valley of
the Kings lasted successfully for three
thousand three and a half thousand years
but since they've been visited they
start to decline and decay rapidly
I think the facsimile is opening up a
whole new level of possibility for
display preservation conservation
restoration communication dissemination
of what's important about these objects
if only we can preserve it like it is
and document it and hand it on to future
generations then there's hope
[Music]
you